[Applause]
who is the name that brings a smile to
your face I'm really famous you know I
go yeah
Oh big problem guy why why why not I
love it it's a name that doesn't follow
the works
this means we either have a Corky or
Aleutian top leg my first game are Ares
this is actually what we're hoping for
top Lucent ah there it is
duty a name that has achieved immortals
is running right over them booty with
the phase dive booty with the Quadra the
fall is it gonna be the Penta pony and
the final game of their spring split
gets up
[Applause]
fantastic Nexus the spring splits
it's a name that people remember
good your knee to knee Mooney Mooney
pooty pooty has arrived everyone's dying
in this fight reckless goes down zettai
gets a bonus
Rudy but before people knew his name his
charm story started with failure this is
his story born in South Korea in 1997 a
young hoon he grew up playing video
games he played so much that his mother
admitted that the amount of time her son
spent in front of the computer was a
source of worry but not enough to act on
since he still managed to do well in
school
Kunie was by no means an immediate
prodigy and has said that being placed
into bronze helped drive him to improve
within a few months his play on the
south korean ladder was enough to get
him noticed and at 17 he became a
practice member for the Samsung
organization he eventually got to try
out for his dream job a potential
starting position with Korean giants SK
Telecom t1 but the team decided to stick
with top laner marrin and who need aside
Adnan to accept a substitute position
with the team meanwhile huni's friend
reignover had also tried out for SKT but
lost the junglers spot to bengi
following the tryouts hooni and
reignover made a fateful decision that
would alter the course of their journeys
they moved to Europe as a duo and joined
fnatic for the upcoming 2015 season I
feel comfortable like to have like young
brother like me because like
I just do better like better than alone
fanatics new roster represented a
changing of the guard as reckless
so as expec a and cyanide all left the
organization even though Affairs and
enemies and the reef we we still be
friends in their life though the latter
two had proven to be good enough for a
season one championship Korea's descent
had shifted the landscape yellow star
would be the only holdover from fanatics
2014 roster adding Cooney reignover Feb
event and steal back ahead of the 2015
season there is no longer any egos in
the team anymore it's a fresh start you
basically building it from the ground up
there is no old tendencies that you have
left in that team but now a part of a
new generation of fnatic players who D
wasted no time in becoming one of the
West's most popular players his unique
blend of in-game skill and aggression
made him exciting to watch he's been
caught out wicked is with so much damage
done before he gets locked up by that
racial tomb now we see wicked rooted in
place Rooney he's gonna put the damage
from a five get out cleanly and his
whimsical and lovable attitude made him
relatable to millions of League of
Legends fans oh you may adjust to them
[Music]
this is a ready to rock hotel
Paddington gets of the water content
without hanging I was in a cohesive up
order to most money for a Rococo Senator
from gate comes out unless introduced
enough not only did hooni make a splash
with fans
he made one in the top lane as well he
led EU LCS top laners in kill
participation and first blood percentage
in his rookie split he ended the split
with a 3.9 kDa a respectable number that
would have been even better if not for
his 65 deaths in 18 games he also had
the highest team death share percentage
28.1% of any top laner to play the full
18 game season stat with the 2 dragon
averages rockets usually want to take 1
a lot later in fnatic
this time around meanwhile though Steve
is getting chunked out by Unni who's
finally gotten rolling and he stunned up
after the flash Mooney follows him
through and solos him down to put it
bluntly hoody was a top laner that took
risks that often paid off loved team
fighting and roaming and didn't care if
he died as long as his team came out on
top
members of rocket know they're stacking
on the bottom side flash holds on the
hoody he's going to not be stunned up
the dark binding doesn't connect
teleports applying yellow star comes in
why is gonna be the one shut down his
yellow star picks it up hoodie still
focused down he'll finally fall and
first divide will push rocket back into
the tower as Steve gets poked down by
the sand soldiers in comes rain over
flash for flash yellow star for a new
tuck and they kill Moony but at what
cost fanatic good reaction depending the
diaper fans who play the game can
respect a solid laner with a more
reserved style of play but they admired
what they saw as one of their own a
young hungry and joyous gamer living the
eSports dream
all of them there are we're all nervous
what is this nervous yes
Oh big trouble of God after finishing in
second during the regular season the
team progressed through the playoffs
first defeating h2k gaming in five games
before taking out the unicorns of love
in the championship match dancing it's
connect something hello sang that's what
we're looking for the first-place finish
guaranteed the team a spot at the
midseason Invitational and became a
point of regional pride for who now
hooni who would you like to face there's
still a lot of teams that are trying to
vie for that midseason Invitational who
do you want to play against I'm not sure
but I once again versus na team because
I want to show show euro LCS is better
than any assist you heard it right here
you better than any guys but before he
was set to compete at MSI he won the
outstanding rookie of the split award
and his reaction like so many other
moments in his first foot was priceless
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming the teams competing in the
2015 midseason Invitational representing
the European League Championship Series
season 1 world champions fnatic
well fnatic had a great storyline
heading into MSI it was unclear how well
they would do against international
competition but after fnatic defeated
TSM and beshi tache eSports Club he
found himself across the river from a
man whose job he had once dreamed of
having as Katie's star top laner
[Music]
marauding chaos of an abandonment day he
didn't inform young for such into
as hooni saw it this was a chance for
him to show the team that had turned him
down that they had made a mistake you
talked about SKT playing around hoody
and now they are doing it it's Korean
Korean
what
and while they didn't win fnatic did the
next best thing
they took SKT to five games and in the
process Huna showed the world that he
could compete against the world's best
fnatic in a team huddle they can
definitely be proud of their performance
almost everybody expected a 3o coming
into today I expected a trio coming in
today and these guys made XK work harder
than they've had to in a very long time
what followed for Guney in the summer
split was the only perfect season in the
West fnatic went 80 Nano and many of
their games were won in dominant fashion
fnatic looked at this game quicker than
we've seen this entire split and fnatic
will become the first team history to do
it the perfect play
Derro
[Applause]
phonetic they're going to finish it
they're going to kill the Nexus and
they're going to Worlds they will
represent Europe
after a 3-2 min over origin in the
summer finals fnatic officially punched
their ticket to Worlds as Europe's top
seed but unfortunately their world
championship aspirations were dashed
following a semi-final exit at the hands
of Korea's
shocked as they sat on stage after the
loss the team that had made LCS history
was cheered on by the Crown Dependencies
once again found himself mashed up
against a Korean team and had been
defeated 2015 marked the first and last
year that hooni would play in Europe as
he and reignover made their way to the
NA LCS for the 2016 season joining newly
established organization immortals after
we actually bent the UL sis and the
event took a bit nal says to the maybe
it's cool to make history again his
reputation as a carry player already
firmly entrenched hoon he even flirted
with the idea of a rule swamp to ad
carry at least there he would be
expected to carry every game
however he chose to stay in the top lane
after a discussion with rain I wanted to
do it better rain over the pull me if I
changed my roleplay to carry then he'll
live from me or on me so I could with
expectations for the roster were high
given the names on the team but those
expectations were met because it wasn't
only huni's fanbase that followed him it
was also his play he Bieber Pearson he
will go in old C's wild Cho gets the
kill picked up and suddenly here's spent
scarin as well knocking back
you still come back and it grabs it
under the naka but his fence Karen just
chasing him down exhaustion even matter
hootie-hoo chance on his name
crushing everybody at quick kill
proposals but that is an ace for one
immortals are dominating immortals got
off to a strong start in the spring
split and the Korean duo were a big part
of why the team was undefeated through
the first seven weeks of rain over and
booney a bunch of damage saves the O for
just now and here goes the team all-sec
is going to be first part of this game
better the backline pub out there dies
as well but still snipe down by wild
turtles going a two for one and rain
over one split school walk into the top
when your arms gonna be in a pretty bad
spot Lance the Cuse well that's the
point blank OC and he's gonna save the
push for the wall the team as he walks
back outside the base finishing first in
the spring split with only one loss to
their name immortals were considered the
favorites heading into the playoffs and
it was in those playoffs that one of who
knees most infamous moments happened
[Music]
this is actually what we're hoping for
I have heard whispers of movies ad carry
top late for practice
and apparently practice what well the
pick was unconventional to say the least
and the team lost that game but that
pick has stuck with him further helping
to identify him as an aggressive carry
top laner for better or worse so ad
carries are really strong laner
so something like Corki is gonna have a
lot of priority mid and even Lucian he's
gonna have a lot of priority top and you
get gold leaf by taking care of early
and you either win with that or if you
go late enough into the game like we saw
you don't have a great comp because
you're missing a tank you're missing a
lot of utility you're also missing
teleport from your mid laner usually so
you lose out to the more standard comms
up tank in the top mid bringing a lot of
utility that series was also the end of
immortals as playoff run as they were
swept by TSM before defeating liquid in
the 3rd place match a lot of damage
coming in immortals still want this
fight right in front of the turret they
want liquid to use all of their
resources so they can get it and push on
through the inhibitor but will liquid
let it happen
immortals is going to make it happen
their goal for piglet who knee hits the
barrel right past liquids members and it
takes down piglet
that's three members down liquid
to keep themselves alive they faltered
in the semi-finals but they're gonna
take down Team Liquid and claimed 20
more championship points expectations
continue to soar ahead of the summer
split and at least in the regular season
the team delivered that's gonna be two
zeros in awfully quick fashion I have to
say well TSM are undefeated and they
have crushed a lot of their opponents
they have not beaten people as badly as
the portals beat a 16-2 record during
the regular season saw immortals only
losses coming to TSM but the playoffs
again we're a familiar story on to the
final deck destroyed itself here comes
the engaged they're trying to make it
happen but chef gun on the hoody effects
man alive the next is now opened up as
cloud 9
and they're going as a wonderful team to
Canada right here our third team
qualifies from worlds are you ready to
see who rounds out this entire picture
in the na regional finals
immortals were the top seed but opposite
them once again were cloud nine and
immortals could not get past them and
would not qualify for Worlds hooni had
spent a whole year in na without a
single international appearance one
Nexus turret down cloud nine with their
eyes on the prize and they're looking to
make it happen 32 minutes and the games
have been very even across the board
back and forth immortals able to grab
one bit cloud nine looking to clinch the
victory
they're leaving on a jet plane cloud
nine are your third seats for na a world
the 2016 offseason brought even more
surprises for hooni given the impact of
his performance he was re-signed by
immortals but shortly afterward he was
approached by SK Telecom t1 the best
team in the world who had turned him
down in 2014
wanted him on their starting roster
Cooney finally had a chance to go back
to Korea and play in the lck but he had
already signed a contract in na while
immortals could have simply enforced the
contract Cooney had already signed
they chose a different approach I just
doing SKT so for this video I just
wanted to say to you guys thanks a lot I
really appreciated that oh look you guys
cheering for me and my supporting IMT
for Tony so I hope you guys are gonna
still you know cheering for me even
though I'm doing okay and see you at
International League for our
championship I will try my best to make
it thanks a lot again good bye
finally after two years abroad Mooney
was coming home
I couldn't imagine I'm joining in like
SDK team I thought that like I could
never get back in Korea to play as pro
gamer incomparably because the lck level
is like was insanely high though he had
accomplished his goal of making it back
to Korea s cuties top lane signing
surprised many fans and his reputation
as primarily a carry player meant that
he had to prove that he could play tanks
if that was what the matter required I
play so most tanks in scream of course
but he's quite good so people think that
people thought that I never played
ranked when I joined when I joined I
know actually when I play na na team
they think that I play just all day like
damaged champion this is a funny go
hoody had played on successful teams in
Europe and North America SKT was a
different beast
[Music]
Kunie started his first split in Korea
by intentionally playing a tank champion
claiming that he wanted to prove his
doubters wrong but in the team's second
week one match he also broke out the
gangplank to remind his opponents that
he could still bring the pain Down Goes
the Nexus and SPT takes another two Oh
victory yeah and the way that they took
this
way better than game number one this was
from start to finish
absolute violation pootie would continue
to play both tanks and damage dealers
throughout the split and if there was
any doubt about who need filling in to
the team Baker put those doubts to rest
well game on they don't and on again
I'll have to get them in a and the team
sixteen to record was good enough for
first place in the LC cash I wonder
who's in his own for the SS further for
either the islands don't wanted at all
but McLean me I miss you guys
I'll be there soon the team made good on
the regular season promise with a three
o playoffs win over kt rolster and cody
remained a threat on either tanks
[Music]
while the year in Korea to this point
might have been considered a homecoming
of sorts summer brought a new set of
challenges an SKT would bring in went
ara as a secondary top laner who knee
ever the upbeat optimist remain
convinced that the system was good for
both players but in the regular season
who knees aggressive and more resource
intensive style was often not what SKT
wanted instead antara safer play was
often what was favored and he would play
25 games to Hoonah 16 antara 177 percent
of his games hooni only 46% and bang
it's just gonna exploit that wolf faster
flash and her knees in no-man's land
baron up super creeps and smacking on
the nexus Ernie wants to find one big
common ground even going to survive and
it's a triple kill for ambition
in the end SKT finished in fourth during
the regular season in Korea's gauntlet
style playoffs SKT would start at the
very bottom of first for the
organization and for the first time SKT
have to play a postseason match not in a
best-of-five that we are undoubtedly
confident in that performance in it's
just a best of three this time as SKT
defeated afreeca freaks samsung galaxy
and kt rolster who knee sat on the bench
he will play two games in the team's
final series against long shoe winning
on gnar and Game three and then losing
on cho'gath in the final game of the
series is going to say goodnight to the
king of the midlane the next and your
new champions of the LT
[Applause]
[Music]
despite the second-place finish in the
summer playoffs SKT had enough
championship points to automatically
qualify for worlds but this too meant
another big question for hooni rules for
worlds would allow SKT to bring only six
players with hooni spot on that roster
unclear the speculation began on line
between hoody antara blank and peanut
one player would have to be left out in
the end SKT decided that hoody would
give the team the best chance to win the
tournament so they elected to take blank
as their since it's gonna be hooni
playing as far as I know in its bright
land instead of antara because the sub
situation was a pretty big topic
actually throughout this year is it
gonna be who knee is it gonna be peanut
is it gonna be antara is it gonna be
blank right you know what is the sub
rotation and they are bringing two
junglers instead of the double top laner
it is time to send it down to the stage
to kick off the 2017 World Championship
after a 5-1 group stage performance SKT
was brought to their limit in the
quarterfinals by surprise European
success story misfits going a full five
games SKT was able to seal the deal and
make it to the semi-finals SKT five
games
in trying to avoid elimination and they
have done so SK Telecom t1 will be your
second team in the semi-finals claiming
victory over misfits gaming with that
victory over misfits Mooney had made
history he had become the first ever
League of Legends player to reach the
top four at Worlds in two different
regions
yeah and for who need he's been on both
sides of this in the semi-finals SKT was
against Chinese powerhouse royal never
give up again it was a tense five-game
series but a massive engage from who
knee would end the series decisively in
his team's favor Chinese members are
falling left and right who's the on the
run he not here to follow soon jumps for
finds the tough to flash away but at the
3v5 can you win this fight and make it
down to two this could be the death now
lose II tried to confirm ooh
that's forward that's gonna be five
that's the ace and the legend of SK
Telecom will not die today Cooney was a
single best of five series away from the
World Championship after all he had
endured his Exodus to the West has
returned to Korea and proving he could
fly tanks his hardships during the
summer split he was so close to the
ultimate goal but Samsung Galaxy had
other plans in life killing in the back
line they found for his duty that that
have a way out pops to go but he has no
exit routes to a more honorable Caleb
down but he gets thrown away they twitch
to their aggro they knock down wolf
instead 5b three in mid that signals the
end of the SKT dynasty there are no
turrets it is five versus three booty do
you have what it takes to
the Nexus the upset is completed the
kilts go bro
[Applause]
Samsung Galaxy their 2017
[Music]
huni's dream of winning worlds as an lck
player instead became a nightmare and it
was a moment that not even the joy as
top laner could withstand regardless it
was not a surprise to see who knee
bounce back he headed back to the only
region he hadn't won a split in the
newly franchised na LCS it has a
throwback who knee played the infamous
top lucien in his first game back Lucian
top I'm I'm fairly certain you know
there's almost no chance that it is
going somewhere else who knees journey
across League of Legends is unique to
return to Korea after leaving to start
his career in the West is unprecedented
to amass so many fans in the process his
heart warming and his contagious
optimism leaves even his most skeptical
fans wondering if another world's
appearance is so unlikely now that he
has left Korea that's why in typical
hooni fashion he views his time with SKT
as a growing experience I prove that I'm
really good and also I got better
[Applause]
and they is really nice to see you guys
again
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button